[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà tu géré mr ho est très très
fort ce qui fait bien sûr jérémy peyrot
des frérots de la vega tu t'éclates tout
seul maintenant aussi tu t'éclates à 2
tu t'éclates tout seul et là ça va très
bien ouais franchement ouais t'as tout
le temps la même marque tu voulais
reprend que ça y est non c'est pas que
j'aurais mars j'avais pas envie
d'arrêter sur tout mais en fait c'est de
commencer ton coéquipier tonton
d'alzheimer maia naïma ton ami wayne est
toujours pas tous pas on se voit
toujours on s'est vus la semaine
dernière yann qu'est ce que tu fais ils
écoutent ce que tu fais tout seul il a
grogné alors jérémy pau n'a pas du tout
pour toi et kroon parce que c'est il va
s'endormir bientôt n'a rien à voir ça
n'a rien à voir avec toi jette pas bougé
il vraiment il n'a aucun problème avec
toi non mais est donc vous savez vous où
il à me dire ce que tu fais ce que tu
fais bah ouais carrément c'est
franchement c'est un carton c'est pas
des coûts non non non pas du tout des
frères vrai nom mercier en tout cas
merci convoque les labos ces démissions
bravo mais moi
jérémy ferait enquête avec tous merci
jérémy c'est vrai que ça cartonne pour
lui julien quelle icône est là le titre
parker valérie bénaïm a même dit ah vous
connaissez le titre parker étaient tous
les branchements o'keefe
voilà merci ce que tu fais et tu es très
beau de le dire est ce que vous êtes
célibataire n'ont pas dit non mais non
c'est prend qui alors rien